...
You
Hi, hi
Hi
My god, you're so loud for me. Hello make me quieter. I'll make you quiet
Hello
Hi pin pals hymen masors, what up?
Hi, you made me so sure
You're like a hundred what forty three centimeters. I don't know but now I feel like I have to match it on my screen
Okay, my bad
Hi, I'm more than a hundred. Thank you
Welcome to the
Collab of all time. Yeah, we haven't not many plans. We're just here to have fun
Girls talk girl talk
Mm-hmm
Are we gonna talk about periods?
Wow, that's something if you want to start off with that then sure
Okay, sure, what's your what's your choice of period product to use?
Pad because my coochie hurt your coochie hurt. Yes. What do you mean by that?
You really want to know the Lord
Did you know that you can have okay? I have a health condition, right? Okay, and yes
I'm shouting this out to the high heavens. Hi pin pals. I'm sorry. You have to find out this way
There's this medical condition called a retroverted uterus
Mmm
Have you heard of that? I think you told me about it. Yeah, it's when your uterus is flipped backwards
Yeah, and it's painful and so my periods are painful. Oh
And so it hurts to put in like a tampon or something
Yes, like it doesn't go into your uterus obviously, but it can
affect
Your kidney meow meow
Oh
retro coochie
Does that mean instead of an innie it's an ellie?
Yes, yes it does
Is it twisted around there is
Like okay, so they the only reason I know this is because they give you like a what is it like a CT scan?
Where they like see all your insights? Mm-hmm, and then
They have like on the paperwork like what what they find in your body, and they always say yeah
Mimosa has a her uterus is backwards, but that's okay. I
Heard I heard that thing can happen with like all of your organs too. I've yeah, I've heard of that too
I think there's a disease where you can
Be born with your organs on the wrong side of your body. Yeah, I've heard of that condition
Um
All right, well I like to use
period cups
Because oh, I'm kind of lazy, and I don't like having to constantly like buy
more pads and stuff and
So that way like I just boil the cup to clean it
And I just I just put it in and it's it's nice because I don't have to change it as often and also
I don't know if you feel this way, but with pads like
It gets really sweaty down there, and it gets really damp and hot
Like the moistness is so uncomfortable for me and every time you like sit down and it like squelches against you
Do you get that?
Yeah, I used to get really heavy periods
Yeah, I hate that feeling so much so I can't handle it
Would you ever sell the the water?
What water? Oh like the water that you boil it in? Yeah. Oh
The water that I boil the cup in? Yeah
Maybe I
Think that might be a health hazard, but I think if I well you boiled it so the bacteria is gone I
Guess I
Guess just don't disclose it to the you know the postal service that it's coochie water
Yeah, do you think they would I think they had sent it back to your hat. No, they'd probably dispose of it
Yeah, but it's just water. I guess at the end of the day
I never used a cup though
Like you you don't put the you don't put the cup in with blood into the into the water when you boil it
No, no, but there could be chunks
You don't get those I do get clots, but I'm saying like it's not gonna be in the water that I sent to viewers
Why not?
I want I want clots and all you want clots and all yeah, you want that soup
The Emmy broth, yeah
It adds some texture
That's pretty gross I heard that you can get like clots like I don't know what what it's called but like
the clots like it's basically when your whole
Uterus uterine line comes like comes off in like one big chunk and it's like uterus shaped
Have you ever gotten those ones? No, I feel like that would hurt
I feel like it would I've never gotten it
But I looked at pictures of it and it's literally like a mini uterus and it's like a blood clot from a period
Yeah, what's it called? Hold on. Let me check I
Need to see this
a
Uterus screenshot if you will yeah, it's like a screenshot
Google just shy to show me period blood clots in general. That's not enough
Oh here
Where is this it?
Do you want to see the picture hell yeah, yeah
I'll take a look. I'll take a ganda. It's like it looks like Jell-O
Oh, no, it says upload failed something went wrong. It doesn't is it like should I send you a Google Drive link?
Sure, why not? I don't know. Maybe
This court is this court is trying to censor me. Yeah, does that have like a filter? It does but you can turn it off
Hmm
Somebody somebody gave me $10 and they said that they want us to kiss. I don't know if that's enough. Sorry, but thank you
Come here
It looked like a giant
I fixed it a little bit. Okay now your head your skull is so what is up with your cranium?
Oh my god, I like how you have a dent in your head. Yeah, I also have the headphone
Dents
The gamer dance
I'm such a huge gamer. So I have a gamer then. Oh, it's a web p-file. Oh my
Oh
That's like the size of your palm that's insane. Yeah, your uterus is kind of small. Yeah
Yeah, I feel like people don't know how small uterus really is it's like a little baby organ. Yeah, it's not that big
Very small
Yeah, I don't like web p-files. I think they're lame
Yeah, I hate when I try to download an image in it. That's what happened
I tried to download the picture itself, but it gave me a fucking web p-file fucking web p's
It's to stop us from stealing images off the internet
Really? Oh, I don't know
Is that is that's the point of them? No, I don't know. I'm just guessing
I'm just guessing
The true question is does it taste like Jill? Have you tried your period blood? Have you tried period blood in general?
Yes, you have
Yeah
Iron it tastes like iron. Why did you try metal? Wait? Why did you try it?
Because I've tasted everything else. Why wouldn't I taste my blood?
Your period blood specifically. Yeah. Yes
What's the story behind this? I got it on my fingers and I sucked it off
How did you get it on your fingers?
wiping
Different okay, it's different
What?
Yours, okay, you're seriously not lying. I'm dead ass
I've tasted my own pee. I've tasted my own Gabagoo, and I've tasted my own blood and my period blood
Tasted your own pee. Yeah, why?
Well, what if what okay the reason why is what if I'm in a like life-or-death scenario and I have to drink my pee
Maybe I am
I need to get used to it
Did you forget to pay your water bill when they shut off your water and you got thirsty? I'm so confused
That actually has happened before but no
But no, you didn't okay. So what how did you taste your own pee?
What pee in a cup like did you just have the idea pop in your head one day? I
Guess I mean
Pee is okay. I like pee. Do you have long-term memory loss? Tell me the story about how you tasted your own pee
I don't know. I was a kid
It's personal it's lemonade on the go exactly. Oh
Well, then how did you know you did it if you don't remember it as a kid did your parents tell you I
Was the freaky kid I
Can imagine
Were you one of the freaky kids?
Not really not that I know of I would try to run away from my parents all the time though in public
I was kind of a kid that needed to be on a leash, but they didn't have child leashes at the time
Yeah, so I
Wasn't allowed to leave the house much because I would try to run away
Like run away run away or just yeah, like run away like I would I would I would just leave my parents
I would run away from them
Yeah, we gotta put you on a leash
Holy crap, I
I
Don't know. I was I had when I was growing up. I had like the the anxious attachment style with my parents
But then I got traumatized and I was like leave me alone. I don't need you
You well, how did you get traumatized?
That is that is a stream and it's
The trauma has been dumped dump it the train you don't want to it's up to you
I mean, it's not my members stream, but if you guys want the TLDR my mom is insane
Okay, and then you didn't you weren't attached to your parents anymore
It's my my
What's it called my villain arc or whatever your villain origin story? Yeah, pretty much
Okay, I feel like a lot of villains have like bad parents. So just check it out. That's true. Are you a villain now? I
Feel like I'm more of an anti hero, but I'll take I'll take the villain. Why not nobody else wants to be the villain
Fine, I'll do it myself
What would you be do you feel like a main character? No, I'm a background character
Really? Yeah
Yeah, I'm the background that I can't you you think of yourself that way. Yeah
That's really sad
Why why are you a side character? I don't know because I don't do anything
Like I feel like I only leave my house if another main character needs me to be in the background
Like your piano teacher
Yeah, I
Used to have a piano teacher who would do the same thing as yours. Just ignore me when I was at the door
Oh, no, she doesn't ignore me. She just told me like it was both of our faults. She texted me saying she
She would be available, you know that week and I never answered her to confirm
I just kind of left her on red and then I came that week and I was like hey
I'm here because you said you'd be available and she's like, oh shit. Sorry. I meant
I meant the the next week or something like that like it's both of our fault
Yeah, she told you walk all the way there, right? Well, no, I take the bus and then I walk like the other half of the way
Yeah, that's miserable
It is especially in the heat, but it's okay because it's literally the only exercise I get when I quit my job
My mom was literally like you get no fucking exercise and you're gonna get fat if you quit this job
It's good for me to have exercise
So that's why I I you know I I stay with this teacher because she's nice even though she's far away
I need I need to I need a little bit of exercise
That's fair
Do you do you ever disclose what you used to do for work, or is that a secret?
Um, I haven't talked about it on this channel, but I can talk about it. I
Know it's not a secret
It's a secret. I guess so far because I haven't talked about it yet. I oh, I'm excited
Is it interesting no not at all
Well, okay, my job history goes in high school
I like did a free internship as a tutor
For like a tutoring service
Kind of like kumon, but like less depressing. Wow
um
Not that wow
and then
After that my first job that I actually got paid for was at a grocery store during cold bed
Oh, and then after that I switched to another grocery store still during COVID and then finally I ended it off at a
drug store
Like at a cuban store, and that's that's that's the gist of all the jobs I've had so far
And I have not yeah, that's not very interesting
I
Thought I thought you're gonna say something like
Yeah, I don't know I don't know what I was expecting
What's your job history I
My first ever job was at a taco place and I quit within two weeks because they were paying me under minimum wage
It was under the table or something or
So it was in the state of Texas and Texas has this law where if they put if an employer puts you on like a
Probationary period they can pay you under minimum wage. Are you serious? Yeah, and I was a kid. I didn't know anybody
So they pretended to put you on some stupid probation
Yeah, so it's like you work here for I think it was a 60 or 90 60 or 90 days
I can't remember and then they're like it then we'll bump you up to minimum wage. Oh
I know about that. I remember when I first got my job. I it was like because I was under age
They were allowed to pay me under minimum wage. Yeah, I think I think that's how it works
It is screwed up because we might be miners, but we're still working just as hard as the adults like what the fuck
It's messed up. They hate the children. They really hate the children
Valid you fall for at first sight. No, Emmys don't fall for the minor. No, she was not the cute
Do not fall for cashier in me
But I I worked it. Okay, I don't think I've said this out loud. I worked at water burger. Oh, no
I
Yeah, we don't have water burger in Canada. Is it good? No, you don't it is so good people say it's mid
But it's like comfort food to me as a Texan
Is it like cheap is that why people say it's mid because I know here a lot of people say that Burger King sucks
As because it's really cheap, but Burger King is also like a comfort food to me
Yeah, it's it's not cheap, but it's
Better than McDonald's is how I feel
Mmm
Gotta say her accent seems rather mild for a text. I'm sorry. You want me to talk like this
This is how my mama talks my mama talks like this really
Yeah, my mom my mom is uh
She's not a southern bail, but she is uh, she's southern. So do you have that accent too and you're just covering it? I
Have it. I just uh, I don't say I'm covering it, but
It slips out sometimes if you pay attention
Okay, okay
You have an accent
No, I have I only have a little sister voice and big sister voice
I don't have I don't have any sort of accent. My mom has an accent though
which is strange because my dad doesn't have an accent even though they're both from the same country and
Came here at the same time in Canada. I don't know
Palais vous Francais
Oui
There I have a shitty Canadian accent when I speak French. I
Mean I'm not Canadian nor do I speak French so I can't hear it
That's so hard to to s
Francais no
No, she's not French. No
Thank God people think I'm French French Canadian. No, no, my family's not from France. She's just Canadian
You sound like you would make a great real gone cover, what's real gone is that like a Texas like a country song?
Real gone. I'll look it up. Can you sing the fucking I dug my key into the side of his can you sing that song?
I could sing that
It goes like that one
Why do you know that song better than me
You're a fake Texan
It looks like it
Yeah, people think that all Texans have like a they all talk like this. It's not true
There's plenty of I mean the further south you go. They do talk like this
But when you're in northern Texas like I was they don't talk like this
I see is Texas near Alabama
Yeah, yeah, have you much yeah, have you met any Alabamian Alabamians that?
I
Committed committed what?
Tell me
Yes, yes, I have a story about that
Tell me I have a story I have a so my family is pretty much from the southern like the Bible belt basically
I have some cousins from Alabama and
I've never told this story on stream. I have a male cousin
Do we see where this is going right?
No, I was a minor. He was an adult and he sent me he sent me photos
Yes
Sweet home Alabama wait of what? Mm-hmm his wee wee his cock
16 by the way it was 24
Yeah, I'm sorry you have to hear this
I
Don't know he was a weirdo. I guess I don't I don't know I haven't spoken to him since that
victim
This is why I feel like I'm a background character because I don't have crazy stories like this
Drake
It was not that big
Like four inches it was hard. Yes
I really I don't know we we went on the lore behind that as we went on like a family reunion
And we went to Alabama like Mississippi and Alabama to see our family
And he said he attacks me on Facebook Messenger and he was like memosa your boobs are so big
I was like, oh
Thanks, I guess
I'm 16 by the way
He said be he said me wee wee pigs. Yeah
And yeah, he the thing is he would ignore me in person, but he would text me weird things
What the fuck oh my god Lulu is here. Hi
What's my queen? She's my queen too a daddy party
What the fuck the only
The only sort of weird thing I have like that is that when I was like really really young I had I have three
Cousins and one of them is much older than the rest of us
And he was like guys, do you want to see something? I found he was probably like 13 or something
He was like guys. Do you want to see something? I found
And he he brought out a camera and he opened it and it was pictures
Like oh my god. I've never talked about this before you there. It was pictures of his mom and and her boyfriend
Dylan each
You just found them
That would change my brain chemistry, that's disgusting
That is so gross
I
What did you do I would cry he offered to send he sent the pictures
We just laughed at it cuz we thought it was funny. That's so why 2k
I
Have you ever caught your parents doing something like that?
No, but my mom and her boyfriend were never secretive about it like literally I would just be in the kitchen
And I would just start hearing them go at it. It was it was not fun
Cuz I was like I can't I can't do this anymore. Yeah, I don't blame you. That's really fucking gross
Oh, yeah, who my parents used to have scheduled sex
Yeah, because my dad takes pills
Oh, and he needs time
Yeah, would it be on like the family calendar or something would it be like in the Google calendar that's shared between each other
I don't know but
It first started when I was like 19 like 18 or 19
I guess they were getting back into their sex life and their the master bedroom was directly above my bedroom
I heard everything
The bed shaking the moaning the clapping yes
Never heard my parents once in my life that is a good thing. Let's keep it that way. Yeah looking lucky. I
Am
traumatized
August 3rd 4 p.m. Spent time with the Mrs.
Yeah, I have very weird parents
My parents are mostly normal
Wow, I can't relate to that at all
It's the rest of my family. That's messed up
Do you have a least favorite family member?
Least favorite I do but I can't well. Yeah, it's my dad
No, you're real for that my least favorite is my mom, so yeah, I can say why cuz I don't really I don't talk to him anymore
mm-hmm, but basically
His dream was always to move to America, right, right, so
He
So my mom and okay, both of them were really really like broke like really really broke and so
They lived at his grandparents house in a different country, right and
So first somehow he got the chance to not go to America, but he got the chance to come to Canada
And so he was like, okay
Yeah, even though, you know, I have like a eight-month-old son over here
I'm gonna dip and go to Canada alone without my mom and so that's what he did
illegally
And then my mom was like, I think she finally had enough money, so she went alone
to meet up with him and then
You know eventually they shipped over the rest of the children
And luckily I was born in Canada though, oh, okay, yeah
I was born in Canada, so I didn't have to get shipped over
But eventually we did get shipped back to our home country because my mom was like
I can't handle these kids alone because my dad wasn't helping
My dad wasn't helping so she shipped us back typical for the grandparents to take care of us for a while and
While the grandparents were taking care of us, I think they got a divorce at that point
Not even a divorce you didn't want to pay for a divorce and he threatened to
like
Leave forever and like disappear like he threatened to disappear, right? He was like if you try if you try to
You know divorce me and get child support
I will leave and you'll never see me again. Yeah, your children will never see their dad again. And so
This is crazy in me lore and so she was like, okay fine
I won't divorce you and I won't get child support from you either because you know, we're not divorced
Yeah
And then finally when we were shipped back back home
My mom just took care of all of her kids alone without him and without child support
Really sad
Really that would fuck me up for life and I met him every once in a while
But he was always just kind of an asshole and I never liked him because like every time I would meet him
He would like criticize me
He'd be like, oh your shirt doesn't look good or like I don't know
He'd say something to criticize me like I liked I don't know
I liked my hair long and he'd always be like no you have to cut it short or like, you know
Why are you wearing that shirt? It's not it's not appropriate or like the way you're dressing isn't appropriate for school
Even though I was a kid and I was just wearing little kids clothes
He wanted me to dress like fancy or something
That's weird. He's a weird fucking guy. I don't like him
Yeah, I don't like him either. I'm gonna punch him through the screen
Yeah, I wish I could punch him, but um, I
Don't want to beat up an old man, I guess
What it's what he deserves it is but you know, I don't want to go to jail for beating up an old man
Elderly abuse. Yeah, elderly abuse
Why do you hate your mom that is a loaded quote you want to know the tea
There's a lot of floors surrounding my mom, but she used to like beat me and kind of like rip my hair out over like church stuff
My dad was a little bit like that too, but not as bad not as bad. I didn't get the worst of it for sure
Oh, man, I def I definitely did I was the last one in the house. So I got the brunt of it. Oh
I'm so sorry
It's okay. It gives you character. It does a little bit. It does. That's why we're here today
We're trauma dumping
We really are supposed to be girls talk
Yeah, I mean, I guess this technically is girls talk. Yeah
We're girls talking sad girl sad girl hours. Yeah, exactly
This is what girls talk about we talk about our trauma and our periods and what else do we talk about
What is fucking
Makeup
I do wear makeup. Yeah, I don't wear a lot
I used to be really into it back in like the like the 2016 makeup era
Oh, God with the with the crazy brows
Yeah, I had eyebrow blindness
I think I might have a picture
I had two types of eyebrow blindness
I went through two phases one when I one where I drew them on really really thick and dark
And then another phase where I shaved them off and I couldn't tell that I shaved off too much
And I just kept shaving
You thought you looked anime
Yeah, I thought I looked cool and anime with my eyebrows like very like very very little eyebrows just at the front a
Little bit. I thought it looked anime
Like how you look right now on the screen. Yeah, we'll worsen this honestly, but yeah. Oh, wow
Like sperm eyebrows. No, not sperm like just completely off and other than like oh my god
That's I that's so I've been too scared to shave my eyebrows. Well, they grow back
They do but what if they what if they take forever? No, they don't they don't take a long time at all
Yeah, they grow back really really fast and I have very little eyebrow hair to begin with and they always grow back pretty fast
Like if you're fucking I don't know have you tried shaving your mustache or like your sideburns or you're like
I don't know any other. I don't know like your your belly. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah
Yeah, if that grows back then your eyebrows will totally grow back too
It's fun to play with them and that way and it's not as stressful that as like
Waxing them because maybe with waxing they might not come back. I don't know that yeah
I've heard that if you pluck them or you wax them too much. They don't come back after a while
Yeah, I heard of that too
The shaving is different because you don't get rid of like
Falakul or whatever Falakul Falakul Falakul. Yeah. Oh, I'm doing that. How do you do you just shave regularly?
Like your legs I try to yeah, like with a razor
Yeah, okay, cuz my mom has always used an epilator. Do you know what that is?
And every time she would be like in me come here
Let me let me shave your legs like let me teach you how to use this cuz it's so easy
It hurts so
Fucking bad and I'd always tell her mom this hurts like crazy
And she'd be like well you'll get used to it and then it won't hurt as much
But it never stopped
It's so painful. I don't know why people do that. I'd rather if I had to I'd rather wax them
Yeah, me too, cuz at least then like I don't know it's like all the pain at once
But with an epilator it like pulls your hair out. Yeah one by one
It's a little machine that pulls your hair out one by one and it's so fucking painful
Yeah, I I learned my lesson from those
I remember they used to advertise some and they're like this is the new quick and easy way to shave your legs without all the hassle
No, it hurts so bad not worth it. And also like the rubbing one too. I remember they were advertising that where it's just like like a flat
I don't know what it's called like a flat handheld like piece of
Plastic or something and they'd be like oh just rub it on your legs, and it'll cut it'll take the hair off
But like it never worked unless you like rubbed really really really really hard. Yeah burn your skin off
What the hell have you tried using those ones?
No, I I almost fell for it, but then I saw people were saying it's a lot of shit. It is a lot of shit
It is
Just be hairy no way. I don't I get overstimulated by hair. Really? Yes
Yes, I I can and it's I I don't know what it is. I have like heightened senses because I'm autistic
I don't get overstimulated by it. I just think it looks ugly
It does to be honest
Yeah, it looks it just looks ugly. So I liked it when I when I have time
I tried to shave
Maybe not during the winter. Oh
Yeah, that's like the what exception we got to stay warm for the winter. Yeah
Pretty much you know
Have you thought about doing laser? I
I think I
Don't know I don't know my I'm blonde naturally, so it's not like you can really see it anyway. Are you lucky bitch?
Mmm
You look you look you bitch. I'm very lucky
It's not fair. I all of my like my entire family has dark hair, but somehow they have really really light
Body hair except for me
I have really really dark body hair and and it fucking sucks because you can see every piece of hair on my body
That really sucks
So even though like my mom is just as hairy as me, you can't even see it
Yeah, I used to
Okay
Wait, I thought you're ginger though. I
Think we've we've broken character a little too much during this stream to have me pretend I'm ginger
Did you think I was actually ginger in real life?
Yes, no, you're fake. I'm fake
I'm not ginger. Is it from the pictures I posted? Yes
I'm not actually
Of course it was fake. Of course it was fake
I
How often do you get your hair cut? I just kind of myself when I feel like it
Same. Yeah. Mm-hmm. I've gotten too much trauma from the hair salon
Like every time I've gone and I've asked. Oh my god, my throat is getting clogged up and I've asked for something specific
They never give it to me
And so I've just I've just resorted to doing it myself at this point
That's how I feel. Yeah, they always take off too much or it looks bad. That reminds me though
When I was in seventh grade, I have this horror story from the salon when I was in seventh grade
This is what I was first getting into anime, right? Um, I
Saw this one clip I can probably find the clip because it's what inspired my hairstyle in seventh grade
And I'll show it to you. Maybe it was it was a it was a clip from this anime
I don't remember the anime, but it was of her dancing in front of the TV
Oh, is that where she's doing like a funny dance. It's pretty. Oh, I know that one. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
in front of
TV
from uh
Mika Kunen de Shinkoke
Um
I don't know. I'll just copy the image just so you have a good uh
visual
So it's this girl, right?
I saw right. Yeah, I remember
I saw that clip and I became inspired and I was like I want that haircut
So I
I pardoned my hair myself and I I tied a piece like a fucking rat tail
At the back I tied it up because I was like, okay. This is the piece that I want. Um out, you know
Yeah, and I went to the hair salon and I I showed
I showed no
I showed her I thought she would judge me for like if I showed her a picture of an anime girl
So I tried to find just humans with like like real humans with like a similar hairstyle without the stupid rat tail, right?
Um, and I was like, okay, I want this pic
I want this hairstyle, but leave leave the rat tail out like leave the part that I tied off
Out of the haircut like I want it to stay long
And she
She gave it to me
And I was like, yeah, she said yes the hair so
She was obviously judging me very heavily and she said yes and see it was like a great clips kind of situation
Like it was like
It was like a really really cheap hair salon
so I came out basically with a
What's it called like a
What's like a the rihanna like the what's it called the you know the fucking uh
I can't think of the the bowl cut but like long
Look, what's the hairstyle?
I'm not sure
I came out I came out with a bob and a rat
You poor fucking thing and I still have a picture from my eighth grade graduation photos having a bob and a rat
Did anybody bully you for it? Oh, yeah, they did
I got bullied for my hair too in middle school
We're complaining except I purposefully chose to have the hairs done
It's my own fault that I got bullied
It's my own
I feel like I had to have been cute. No, it was really bad
It was really I looked really greasy because oh I didn't know how to style it
And I don't want ever showed me so I would just use a bunch of hair
I gloved it on there to try to make it look as
Yeah, I I actually had a similar story
Have you heard of power puff girls z like the the anime version of power puff girls?
I um, I wanted my hair to look like uh
Buttercup like in the anime where she had like the bob thing going on
And so I printed out a pig I was like 10 by the way
I printed out a picture of her and I showed my mom mom. This is what I want and she said no
And she saved my life that day. She saved your fucking life because my mom said yes
My mom said yes
But I mean it's not terrible. I don't know
But for like a nine-year-old
I don't know how they wouldn't it's basically a pixie cut, right?
Yeah, kind of it's like spiky. I think yeah spiky on top
But I I did have a pixie cut and once I graduated high school. Oh, that's cute
I think pixie cuts can look cute
They can I wasn't very good at styling it though
Yeah
Me neither. I used to I I didn't know how to use like well
We had a curling iron, but it was so old that I um
It wouldn't heat up enough for me to use it
Is your mouth perpetually open or are you yawning?
I'm yawning. I'm sorry. I just woke up
You noticed
That's that's why I keep being quiet because I'm like, uh, it's okay
Um, but yeah, I didn't know how to use a curling iron
But I really wanted more volume in my in my bangs
I had like the emo bangs, but I really wanted more volume
This was in like a ninth grade and so I would choose to just braid my bangs in like really really tiny braids every night
In the morning I would undo the braids
So that they were really curly, but I have very very straight hair
So I just had like really curly bangs
And really straight hair for the rest of my head and it looked really bad
But it's all right. Yeah
No, I used I used to do something similar where I where I'd only straighten the front pieces of my hair and the back would be
The back would be
Oh
What happens is the back of your hair is none of your business. It's really not my business. I can't see it. So it doesn't exist
Yeah, who cares? Yeah
If you can't see it, then fuck you
If you can't see it, then it's just don't tell me about it. It doesn't matter. It's not a big deal. Yeah, it's not your business
It's not your business
Yeah, I was my hair can't hold a curl though
So I could never curl my hair
Do you have straight hair?
It's like
I think I was told it's like a 2a hairstyle or like hair type or whatever
Because there's like different kinds of hair
It's like has like a slight wave to it
It's what the hairdresser told me. Oh, that's pretty though. Thank you
And when I brush it it gets kind of fluffy
That's pretty
Yeah, I wanted to get a perm but I heard that like fries your hair off
Oh, but you only live once so cares if you don't and your hair grows back
Yeah, like I definitely have thinning hair because I like kept it dyed for like six years straight
But like, you know, you only live once you only have one head of hair once just have fun with it
Do whatever you want. Who cares if it gets damaged
That's how I feel like it grows back. Yeah, it grows back
exactly
My hair's my hair grows pretty fast anyway, so I won't miss it. Yeah, just get a perm
Okay, I'm gonna do it my I I um
I went from bleach blonde to black and now I'm red like a reddish black. So
My hair is about to fall off
No, fuck it. We ball. Well, you should definitely tell the hairdresser that your hair
is uh
is
You know died like that though
Why should I well because they need to know
I don't what if like it could like uh, like snap off if they fry it to know your hair dying history. Yeah, that's true
They need to know and at the point I I think I think even if you lie to them, they can find out anyway
Yeah, they'll find out if there's no point something fucks up. They'll find out
It's like a doctor. They need to know your medical history. That's true or a dentist. They need to know
Yeah, they need to know you gotta tell them
Even though I don't like I don't like hair hair stylists or or you know hair colorists in in general
If you want to go they gotta know
I usually just dye my own hair. I don't trust anybody me too
The reason I don't trust anybody is because um
The first time I went to get my hair dyed. I wanted purple
And I showed them like bright purple hair and I was like, this is what I want
And we went to a professional place and I was like, this is what I want
And they're like, okay cool
And they come over and they show me a hair sample and they're like
We can't really give you that but we can give you this and it was still really purple, right?
So I was like, cool. That's fine. I'll take that too. And then I come out of that
salon still having black hair
And you know, they showed it to me in the mirror and I was like, oh my god. Thank you so much
Oh my god. Thank you. I hate that part when you fucking hate it and you're like, oh, thank you
Yeah, thank you so much. Wow. I love it. So it just looked black. Yeah, it was black
I went to school the next day and I was like, I told my friends like guys
Do you notice anything different about my hair? And they're like, uh
No
And that's sad. It was only like two weeks later that someone
Finally at school noticed something was different with my hair and they said, oh my god. Amy. Did you dye your hair brown?
I would cry that would hurt my feeling so bad
I did cry and that's that started my um, my saga of dyeing my own hair
Yep, I feel like it's so much better because you have so much control and you can
You know pick with the color and if it turns out bad, there's only one person to blame
It's you yourself. Yeah. Yeah, especially yeah
And you don't have to deal with like hair stylist being like, oh, it's gonna damage your hair if you do that
Oh, they're always like, yeah, if we bleach your hair, we put dye and it's gonna fry. Well, fuck you, bitch
I'm paying you a service. Hey, why die my fucking hair? I'm paying you to fry it. Just fry it
Do it. Do it. I wouldn't do it myself
Yeah, exactly and I get to do it for cheaper when it's on my own. So you're missing out, bitch
True. They charge so much money to do
I remember I got really lazy once and I didn't want to do my roots
It's when I had uh, it's when I had like red hair. I got really lazy. I didn't want to do my roots
So I finally went to a hair salon, right?
And I told them like, hey, I want to do my roots and they were like, uh
They didn't I think the lady didn't pay attention. So she was like cool come in, you know, like at six
Um, and it'll only be like a hundred dollars and I was like, yo, that's pretty that's a pretty good deal to just get my roots done, right?
That's not bad. Yeah, that's really good deal
And it was a nice place and I come in that day and the hairstylist looks at my hair and then she was like, um
Actually, it's gonna be three hundred dollars and it's gonna take eight hours
So you have to come tomorrow and I was like
Fuck this. I'm just gonna do it myself in four hours. What do you mean? Just for your roots?
Just for my I had a pretty good amount of roots, but it wasn't that much
It was not that much roots. I had so pissed. I just did it myself at that point
But um, I ghosted them that next appointment because I was like, oh, yeah. Yeah, sure. I'll do it
And now every time I walk by that hair salon. I hope they don't recognize me
Three I can't play three hundred dollars for your roots that I I would stab somebody
I was I was annoyed, but I I said yes because I was like, maybe I'll go
But then I realized that that's crazy and what's the fucking point. So yeah, I never ended up falling
Thank god, screw them. Yeah, screw them screw them
I'm a family member who's a hair stylist do the Canadian hair stylist just suck. No, it's obviously the american ones too
Yeah, I don't know what it I don't know if it's just like they just don't give a shit or they're just money hungry because I
I think they make commission maybe on top of hourly depending on where they work
Oh, so do they try to like sell you their products?
It depends like some of the places I go to they try to upsell like shampoo and shit
So I don't know if maybe they get a percent from that. Oh, they probably do. Yeah, that would make so much sense if they got a percent from that
That's bullshit. Yeah, it's actually how it is. Oh, okay. Yeah, I guess it's true. Yeah, I don't know
And it's bullshit and it takes so long to get your license
So maybe that's why they're like money hungry
Maybe but I don't know like
I
Just just come my hair
Come my hair woman. Yeah
If I can do it myself this easily, you know, why can't you do it?
You're paying for this you're paying for the skill that the the years that it took to develop this skill or whatever
Didn't take me years to develop the skill. Yeah, it's I've been cutting my hair since I was a teenager screw you
Get on my level
As a barber, I can tell you that's exactly how they teach you to act in stores. All colors and sales are very much pushed
Even barbers, but men don't care about about their hair health or their hair color
Even a barber. I feel like it depends of depends. But I've yeah, I've never met a guy who really cares about his hair color
Yeah, they use like five in one shampoo. They don't yeah
Go to the hair salon and see like the fancy conditioner and they're like, oh, maybe I need to smooth their hair
I feel like they don't care about that
Maybe it's like a different level of care
Is it the beard?
It's like you want a smoother beard a lot of men care my haircut cost me 30
Well, my haircut cost me like 50 for a trim. Yeah, what the fuck that's not a lot
20 in one
No, it ain't
You
That's so gross your hair is gonna get so dry that it's gonna fall off
That's why it's falling off
Because you're using five in one
Why yeah, why do not more men dye their hair dye your hair? I know it's fun. Maybe they're scared of it falling off
Yeah
Just do it. It's okay. It's fun
Have fun with it. I think they just maybe don't care that much
Maybe I don't know. I'm not a man. Me neither. Contrary to popular belief
Someone saw voice mod on my uh, pc like, uh, what's it called like my home my home page on my pc
They saw voice mod and they're like, she's a man
I fucking knew it. I fucking called it. She's a man
I
Wait, I have a question
Yeah, did people I don't I'm just gonna say this bluntly did people acknowledge that you jack off
Like in your streams
Like do they just sit here and they're like, yeah, I just listened to your audio and it was so great
Do they come in here and say that sometimes? Yeah, I think so
I'm but imagine you're just like I just I don't know. I've never had that happen before so I just
Is that normal?
I'm drugging my penis to your audio right now
Just thought you'd like to know you should see my marshmallow. They go way crazier there
Yeah, it's normal
They're like, hi. I mean, thank you so much for that newest twitter audio. I came to it like five times
Yeah, that's what they say and it's normal
You're welcome
No, it just it's just funny to me because in any other streamers chat you would get bonked so hard
I just I like that. I just I appreciate the difference like respectfully
Yeah
amazing
It's just refreshing
I guess because a lot of I mean, it's not nobody has to do something if they're not comfortable with it, but
It's nice to see people who are comfortable with it
Yeah
Of course. I mean, we kind of have to be comfortable with it. No, you're being forced
I'm here against my will
They they they stole my passport and they said if you don't join feel or we're stealing your identity and putting you in
thousands and billions of dollars and no
Yes, you're supposed to join your penis to the audios though personally whenever I listen to nsfw audios
I don't I don't jerk it. I just kind of listen to it for the artistry sometimes
That's how I feel. I don't I don't sit there. I don't jerk it. I just listen. Yeah. Yeah
That's really what I did. I would just listen like while I'm doing something
Yeah, the professional appreciation of the audio. Yeah
This is before I really knew anything about like asmr or anything. I just uh, I liked the scenarios. I was like, oh
Let me listen to it. It started early. It started on um soundcloud
I found them really soundcloud. Yeah
Did you know that there's there's asmr role play on soundcloud like x on soundcloud? I've never I did not know that
Yeah, I found a hope my first one was a home stuck
And I don't know much about home stuck to this day, but let me see if I can still find the first one I found
I don't know if it's still up. Is that embarrassing?
Is it
I mean, I don't like home stuck so to me it is
I don't know anything about home stuck
but
I thought it was fun. I heard that the fandom is crazy
It is I haven't heard much of the fandom since like the 20
pens though. Yeah, they're not it's not as popular anymore. Okay. Let me see home stuck
Ex-listener
Oh god. Oh my god. Home stuck ex-listener. I don't know if they'll be okay. This must not be it
I need to know the home stuck characters. Hold on home stuck because it was a specific character
It was the nerdy one
I don't I don't really remember the characters either. It was kankeri
It was kankeri. It was kankeri ex-listener
Oh god
There's genshin. Oh my god, there's not safer work stuff on soundcloud. Is that allowed?
Yes, bless you. It is allowed. Thank you.
Sorry
I can't find it, but there's a lot of there's a lot on soundcloud
Oh
Seth ex brat team. Oh my god. Oh my god brat tabing asmr on soundcloud.com
Wow
And it's kind of good
Really?
The comments are funny though
Actually, no, it's very usually it's kind of cringe. Oh, no. Yeah, the voice comments are usually kind of suck
Yeah, the comments are usually filled with kids
You
Who else is listening to asmr boyfriend roleplay on soundcloud?
It's cute. You maybe
Audio's downloaded off of new grounds. What is that? Oh my god new. Yeah, but you don't know about new grounds
New grounds is the best place ever in the 2000s. What's new grounds?
It's like a it's it's like an animation website
But I think they have other stuff there, too. I don't know. It's been I haven't been on that website in a long time
Is he's too young for new grounds? I think new grounds.com. I've never
It's an animation website
I think it's like
They wasn't just animations. I think they what else do they post? I don't remember they have games there, too
I feel like I recognize the
I recognize the
Okay, hold on. I'm gonna go get more water
Okay, don't don't choke. Okay
She sounds like she's dying
Oh, so it's not just like
Okay, I thought it was just like animation and like games, but apparently it's like a lot of stuff
Didn't they used to have pornography there?
I'm young, but I know about new grounds here
I will give you your your medal because people who I'm surprised a lot of people don't know about new grounds anymore
Don't they still have prawn probably wait do y'all remember the the the rhythm heaven prawn thing?
Yeah
What is poontag wait am I gonna I'm gonna look this up? What is that?
What is that? Is that a typo?
That feels like a typo
Okay, I'm back
Welcome back
What are we talking about?
The horrible uh the backstory of new grounds. What's the backstory of new grounds? I'm too young to have heard of this
There's lots of prawn there. There's prawn
Yeah on new grounds
unadulterated prawns on my christian wholesome website new
What do you have to search to find it? Uh so that I can make sure to avoid it
I don't know. I'll I'll I'll take one for the team. Okay
So I'm gonna type I'm gonna type in sexy
Type in boobs type in girls
Girls
Wait there actually is some stuff dead girls kissing god why can't that be me?
You need an 18 plus account to browse the the prawns
That's lame
Oh, they have an 18 plus section
But so is this like is this like
Deviantart or something?
I think it's like 10 times worse
Why?
They had some pretty crazy stuff there
Derpyxion
Should I make an account? Did they check your real ID if you make an 18 plus account?
I don't know that's a good question
I'm gonna try making it
Oh, wait, I have to no account sign up. Really? What? Hold on. Wait, can you not sign up?
Hold on. Oh, man. I'm making it. What should my username be type it to me on discord
So people try to friend request me on new grounds
Old flat art flash game and animation community website that was very popular
That's inspired by me use that username
Okay, okay
Nobody will ever know
Is
Yes, create my account
I have to hold on I have to um
I'm surprised it's still up and going
Um, please click click here to validate your account. Okay. I did it. Okay. So you buy it. They wanted me to search up
Zone and derpyxion
Derpyxion, okay, derpyxion
What is it it's just really bad art
I've never heard of that person
How do I see like eco raptor? How do I see there are only? I don't know
I haven't been on this I haven't been on this website since like 2010
Derpyxion
I'm only finding fan art of derpyxion. I can't find their actual account
Logs help me guys help me
I'm also surprised that derpyxion is one help me find derpyxion
Is it blogs? Is it like accounts? Oh derpyxion posted. Oh wait, I reckon that wait
Why do I recognize some of this guy's work?
How do I sort by latest art? Okay
It's pretty basic art
Where's the prons movie section? Okay the movie section latest movies. Okay
There's only two here on underpyxion's account. I'll go to the promo Chan one
That's loud. Um, okay. I'm gonna mute it
Okay, it's just a boobs. It's just a animation of a girl bouncing with her boobs bouncing
That's not that's not special. That's not special
I was expecting something more graphic
Derpyxion. Oh derpyxion
Oh somebody misspelled it derpyxion
Toggle off mature and toggle on adult
Where do I do that? I don't know
Maybe like settings
Account settings
Zontan by derpyxion on new grounds, okay
Where do I do that?
Um
Your feed no they're trying to get me to pay
Really they might have money. They want my money
Restricted content. Fuck it. I'll sign up too
Account settings content filter options. Oh
Um
There's no option for content filter content filter options edit content specific art
No, all of the oh there it is adult. Okay, there we go. Now I did it
Now let me find derpyxion derpyxion
A blast to the past
I
Feel like I'm gonna be really disappointed latest movies, okay all this effort for that there is more now
Um, which one was your favorite give me your favorite derpyxion
Oh god. I don't know. It just looks like
Basic, uh, what do you eat generic? Yeah, it looks like generic, uh prawn. What wait a minute. Why is your chocolate crunchy?
It's a chocolate bar
It it's crunchy
Are your chocolate bars soft?
Yeah, what? Yes. Hell. Yes. I don't like the hard chocolate bars
Oh, I can when it's a little bit melted
It's the it's bueno
Bueno, you never heard of bueno? No, what?
I've seen one of these I've seen mine and mine and dash I've seen this one
Let me watch the whole thing
Take well for the team
All right, would you like me to screen share to you?
Sure, why not? Okay
I must know what's happening. Obviously. I cannot share it to youtube
There you go
I can't put me a hentai horse
Oh, it says heroes. It says heroes never mind. Sorry Freudian slip
That was an advertisement. Okay. Freudian slip. I don't have the sound on so it's it's without sound. Hi
Mime and dash. Okay. There's the guy walking. Yeah, he's the guy walking in like some uh the mask
What is this some
Bon Bon and choo choo. Oh no
Other cute. They're like furries. Welcome. Good sir. Here to play a game
Well, they have money and boobs just guess our acts right and win
Do you want to do want to voice one of them? Sure. Why not?
Question one
Uh finger my asshole finger my asshole
Oh
Why is her butthole so little
Not the one of the two of the pink and one of the
Six
Okay, oh, oh he got it wrong. He got it wrong. You're dumb ass. How'd you get that wrong?
You're making me choke up on water
What it head oh head. Yeah, I'm gonna fuck their face
Hmm
Oh
What the fuck
I can see why people would like this. I guess is this is this what you guys watch?
This is pretty normal. Yeah, this is pretty normal. I guess it's well animated. I mean, it's not bad
Yeah, that was fast
30 second gooner over here. Yeah, that's sad
The shape shifter is the best
Uh, this is kind of okay
This is getting I thought this was gonna be like cursed or something
No, it's it's fairly normal for in terms of prawn. Yeah in terms of prawn is fairly normal
How much goo does he have in him? Well, it's obviously, you know, it's uh, it's an exaggeration of real life
He got it wrong again
Dumb ass. It's just well animated western prawn. I guess so. Yeah
Oh, is this like a rope?
Uh-huh because she's floating
Get shibby in here
shibby
Shibby shibby. I'll get shibby in here. I'll get shibby in here
Their pick son doesn't really do any cursed stuff. I thought I thought I was gonna get some crazy stuff
Yes, it's just yeah, they're just going at it. They're just going at it
The end. Wait, did he die?
They stole his money at the end. That's what he gets
That's insane. I can't believe we just watched that. Oh the bonding moment. It was real. Yeah, it was bonding for sure
Mm-hmm
Are we waiting for dirt picks on new grounds? It was all right
It was okay. Yeah, it has 20 million views. I can see why it's popular
Watch the shape shifter one. Is that one curse? I want to curse stuff. I don't want to just watch the stuff you jack off to
How do I know it's the shape shifter one?
I
We don't have cursed stuff watch the cursed prince. What's the none of these are titled the curse prince
I can't tell which one is the shape shifter one
And
Fander tails cursed prince
Fandal tails
Like I want like fucking tom is the tank engine level
Tron
you know
Yeah
That makes a lot of sense
Like oh fandal tails the curse prince of that. Oh, that's that's the title. Okay. Oh, wow, there's like plot
I hate plot really. I like I like a little I fucking hate it. I'm not here to listen to your life story. I'm here to goon
I like a little plot though. I feel like it makes the gooning experience better when it gets to the actual like goon part, you know
I just skip it
Yeah, I skip it. I like it. It's like a filler episode. No, it's the build up. It's the build up that looks good
Yeah
This is just one guy that animated all this. It's really well done
Um, yeah, this is the shape shifter one is also pretty uh, I mean, I guess it has like some blood play in it
Which I guess oh show me. It's really not a lot. It just showed
I don't even know if I can find the time stamp anymore
Derpixon is a girl. Well, she's very uh talented
She is she's very talented. I hope she gets hired by like a an actual uh
Or hope she got hired by an actual uh, imagine using this as like your portfolio
That would be great. That would go hard. That would be bold
If it's really well done that really enhances the goon
The plot? Well, I guess yeah, I guess the plot. I don't know
Is that wait, did they did they also do the da da da da da da da da da na na na na?
Did they do that one?
Oh, wait, no that was a different guy. I remember. Uh, I forgot his name
But he also did some other tiktok stuff that went viral
Zone that's zoned. That's zone that's zoned. Oh
Wait, so zone was on the srananas website too minus one
Latest audios, Latest movies.
We can link her stuff.
Nooo.
Oh here it is, Ancazone.
Ohhhhh.
This person, oh wow he's done Teen Titans stuff too!
Oh that's...
Teen Titans.
Are you a Teen Titans fan?
I really like, what's Starfire's big sister's name?
Blackfire.
Blackfire?
I like Blackfire.
She's so mean, I love her.
Is she the emo one?
Oh.
Yeah.
She's so mean.
Wait, wasn't there more emo ones?
Or am I emo?
Raven?
Yeah.
I've never watched Teen Titans, I don't know.
Currently I am watching Starfire getting pinned by a tentacle monster though.
Oh wow.
You guys are crazy.
Is it any good?
Why do you want to know?
No, it's got like, I don't know, this is too intense for me personally.
Really?
Yeah, it's just a lot of tentacle stuff going on.
I'm not a fan of excessive gum, you know?
Oh yeah, that's kind of nasty.
It's too much, it starts to look like old milk, it makes me think of curdled milk.
The way they're drawing in this one especially, it just makes me think of curdled milk when
there's a lot of it, so I don't like excessive gum.
It's disgusting.
Disgusting.
Hinka P.
Blackbird.
I'm not watching, I'm not watching any more of your recommendations for Pran.
I don't want to see any more of it.
You got to pay for that.
Yeah, wait, what?
What?
Pay to have me watch the recommendations, is that what you mean?
Yeah, why not?
It's an experience, it's a bonding experience.
I guess that could be a fun idea.
Yellow gum.
I might just like shit on it the whole time though.
That's what I would do.
Yeah, I think I might just like critique it.
Yellow gum.
It's better when it's yellow, wait, what?
Side eye.
What?
Wait.
Does it get yellow somehow?
Are you talking about, are you talking about?
Maybe with an infection.
What?
Why would you want it to be, if it's mixed with pee?
What do you guys mean when it's yellow, what does that mean?
That is disease, does it get yellow sometimes?
It gets yellow when it's old.
Like when it dries?
If it's, yellow one tastes better.
Oh, that just reminds me of like curdled milk.
Like really old, if you eat a bunch of beetroot it can be pink.
That's cute.
That is kinda cute.
If I was a guy who specifically eat love.
That's really pop.
Yeah, that's really pop.
If I was a guy who specifically eat a lot of beetroot so it can be pink, so my gun
can be pink and sparkly.
That would be so cute.
It would be so cute.
I can't do it right now though.
I'll just get an infection.
Eat pineapple.
I don't like pineapples gross.
What?
I love pineapples.
I'm not a fan.
You're not a fan of pineapple.
Why?
Well, first of all it eats you alive.
It burns you.
It's just a little bit acidic.
Do you like octopus?
What?
It's okay, and not really.
Okay, I don't know, I was gonna say octopus would probably-
Yeah, what was your point?
Well, don't you know, like, people like to eat live octopus, too.
Oh, yeah, I don't think I could. That would feel so slime.
What if their suckers get stuck in your throat and you choke on it and die?
Yeah, that happens.
It does happen.
Dr. Pepper withdraws. I'm surviving.
Oh, yeah, you said you're only doing one Dr. Pepper day instead of, like, three?
Yeah.
How's it going?
Empty calories.
I haven't had one in 24 hours.
Are you going through withdrawals?
Yes, I'm tweaking.
You're feeling okay?
Do you need to go get a Dr. Pepper?
No, it's okay. I've been drinking so much water.
It curbs my craving.
I was so proud of you for drinking water.
You better- you might want to stop doing that.
Because I'm weak to that.
Weak to what?
Praise.
Weak to praise?
Yes.
We're drinking water.
Yes, I was starved of attention as a child.
Well, then I'll keep praising you. You're doing- you're doing amazing.
Thank you.
Oh.
Why do you like Dr. Pepper more than the other ones?
I went through a Dr. Pepper phase, too.
Because it tastes superior.
Really?
Yeah, I don't like- Coke is okay.
Pepsi is too sweet. Dr. Pepper feels just right.
Tell them also she's a good girl.
Hahaha.
Would you like that?
No.
Okay, I won't then.
I won't.
I'm sorry, I meant to say yes, sorry.
Yeah, you're giving me mixed- you're giving me mixed answers here.
Sorry, I have problems.
I feel like it should be the other way around.
What do you mean by that?
Like, you're the one with like the more mother model.
Yeah, does she know?
No, she knows, she knows, she knows.
She does not know.
But didn't you choose- didn't you say you specifically asked to have boobs with this model?
Yeah, so my PL- my PL is a loli and I was like, I'm tired of not having boobs.
So I wanted boobs and I asked for boobs and they gave me boobs, so now I have boobs.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
I just- yeah, okay, that's good that you got what you wanted though.
Yeah, because I mean the- like the- what's it called?
The flat- like the cutting board jokes kind of get old because I streamed for so long as a loli and I was like,
I've heard these jokes for four years now.
Can we- can we get over with?
Mmm, okay.
I- I never really got many cutting board jokes.
I used to get them- no, I never got really many cutting board jokes.
No, no, but I streamed more as- I think I might have streamed just as long as like a real life person.
So I think they weren't exactly allowed to make cutting board jokes with me.
Uh, okay.
We appreciate flat here.
Yes, of course we do.
Of course we do.
Minecraft super- super flat world, ah.
I mean your dress is green.
It is, and my buttons are brown. I'm basically Minecraft themed.
You are.
I should put a block on your head.
Uh-uh-uh.
Here you go.
I want to- I want to stick to your head.
Oh my god!
Is it sticking?
It's like stuck- it's stuck behind your head on my screen- oh whatever, we'll put it behind your head.
How did you put that there?
I- I have no clue why it's behind your head, but it's just there.
It's in front of my head for me.
Really?
Yeah!
Shit, if it works and it works.
Move me!
You can move me over.
Which direction? Left or right?
Whatever direction you want, so you can find the Minecraft block.
Why won't- I won't go on top.
Maybe I have to change like the layer order.
Minecraft block.
I don't know- I don't know why I won't go on your head.
Why are you waving it around?
You're blocking me with it.
I'm trying to- I'm trying to stick it to your head.
Oh yeah, it's on your stream, it's going behind my head, but on my stream, it's in front of me.
How do I-
I can't control the block at all, I don't think.
It's there.
The software hates us.
Yeah.
Ahem.
Mmm, what were your- what were your favorite games as a kid? Like video games?
Team Fortress 2?
That's all. I played like Left 4 Dead 2 and Team Fortress 2 exclusively, pretty much.
And Toontown.
I don't even know what Team Fortress 2 is.
We're gonna have to put you in the game right now.
Team Fortress 2. Is it like a shooter game?
Yeah.
Oh, this looks like- I think I'm gonna offend people if I say that.
My guard is on high.
Isn't this wasskibbity twi-
This looks like the skibbity twi-
I'm flabbergasted.
Is this not it?
It's-
Kind of, but like not really.
Like they all- I think they all share the same engine and therefore they share the same assets, but it's not from TF2.
I think it's Gmod or Half-Life, yeah.
Wait.
Gmod?
Gmod looks different.
Wait, Gmod also has similar characters.
Yeah, they're all made by Valob.
Oh, is that why they look so similar?
I guess so, yeah.
They used to share assets between the games, I guess, to save money.
Oh, oh.
Would they share character models too?
Cause that's what it looks like.
I don't know how the games work.
It's less that they share them.
I think it's just because they have the same engine and same assets.
I don't know.
It's kind of complicated now that I think about it.
Skibiti was made in Gmod.
Oh, okay.
It's the source.
Skibiti dub dub dub.
Gmod has Half-Life models and everything.
No way she doesn't know what Gmod is.
Let me please-
I was never a gamer.
It's more the fact that I'm not a gamer than being a swimmer.
That's fair.
Yeah, like my favorite games as a kid were like-
Okay, when I was older, it was a furry role-playing game.
When I was younger, it was like-
I didn't really play many games other than-
I played like Mario Kart on the DS and stuff.
Like Super Mario Bros on the DS.
I never got a DS.
No?
No, I didn't.
No, I wasn't raised with-
My parents didn't allow me to have consoles.
Oh, why not?
Because they didn't believe in them.
What is that?
Were you not allowed to watch TV either or something?
I wasn't-
No, it's so weird.
I don't understand because I would ask like-
Mom, I went to PlayStation for Christmas and they'd always say no.
But they gave me pretty much free access on the internet.
So I don't really know.
But I wasn't allowed to watch or read Harry Potter.
Why?
DEMONIC.
It was demonic?
To my parents, yeah.
I don't think it's actually demonic.
I think they're crazy.
Oh, no, yeah, they're definitely-
Yeah, my parents are very, very, very religious.
Oh, that makes sense.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
I'm putting my phone on the charger, sorry.
It's okay, it's okay.
You're clicking around.
Yeah.
When I played Toontown, I always played a cat.
Because I'm original.
I don't even know what Toontown is.
Oh.
I've never played this either.
Is it like Disney?
It was Disney, then they shut it down and then they have like
a community-run version of it now.
And it's not Disney anymore?
Not Disney, just random people running it, I guess.
Why do Christian parents dislike specifically Harry Potter?
I don't know.
I think it's because they equate it to witchcraft.
And witchcraft is bad for them.
Yeah.
Satanic or something.
Pretty much, yeah.
The witches.
The witches and wizards.
Yeah, Satanic Panic was a very real thing.
My parents, my dad will be 70 next month, so.
Oh, that's old.
Yeah.
I think maybe there's a little bit of the that remaining in him.
Satanic Panic?
Yeah, they were terrified of Satan.
It was like fear mongering, I think.
A moral panic consisting of over 12,000 cases of Satanic ritual abuse.
Unsubstantiated cases.
So wait, people were like scared of Satanists at the time?
Because there were allegations of Satanists.
Abusing people?
Something like that.
Is that it?
I've heard that like the Satanic ritual abuse.
I heard that some people are playing it up to feed into their own agenda,
but I have no, I don't really read too much on that sort of thing.
That's funny.
That's like cartoon level.
Like, ooh, it's the Satanists that did it.
It's the witches.
Burn them at the stake.
DnD is Satanic.
Oh yeah, like stranger things.
Wait, they thought DnD was Satanic?
Isn't that just a role-playing game?
That's like ultimate evil stuff.
It's nerd stuff and people, I guess because there's like all sorts of different kind of like stuff in there
that could be seen as demonic.
Religious people did not like that, I guess maybe.
That's crazy.
Witches and wizards and demons and succubus and incubus.
They were scared of content and activities.
Some churches burning in Europe didn't help.
That's crazy stuff, dude.
They keep up with each other too much.
Mind your beeswax.
Role-playing was like being possessed by a demon friend.
I was possessed by a furry demon then.
Wait, I went through a phase where I was a furry and then somebody tried to groom me and I stopped being a furry.
How were you a furry?
Back in the day when I was in middle school I used to, I got into drawing furry art
and then a 30 year old man approached me and he was like hi and I was like oh hi
and then he tried to groom me and I was like no thank you and I left.
Did this really happen?
Yes, I can send you my DeviantArt.
Oh, you were posting it on DeviantArt.
Yeah, let me grab it.
Don't tell anybody, this is like my deepest darkest secret.
I never posted my furry stuff on DeviantArt.
I just had it in my art book, that's all.
I sent it to like my one friend who could have been a 30 year old man.
I don't know.
Oh.
He sent me because the reason why I think he was catfishing or they were catfishing is because we were both the same age
and she was like oh we should send selfies to each other and I sent her like a really shitty selfie because I was like a fucking kid.
And she sent me like the prettiest like fucking Myspace level like emo girl cute selfie and I was like oh my god you're so much prettier than me.
But now that I look back on it I'm like
That's sus.
Maybe that's a little sus.
Yeah.
Oh my god, your art was so cute.
I drew like the same stuff.
Thank you.
Oh my god, skittles.
Oh, it's so cute.
Thank you.
It's so cute.
I love it so much.
Here, let me send you some of my furry art.
I don't have it.
Yay.
I don't have a DeviantArt for it, but I'll just send you like pictures.
It's like the same sexy.
Oh shit, I can't on this computer profile.
Nevermind.
Nevermind, I don't have it.
It's a sad day.
It's a sad, sad day.
Sounds like a fed.
They thought I was a 30 year old man.
They're trying to bait you out.
Yeah, I mean, oh wait, maybe, oh no, I don't have it on this.
Or do I?
I'll put a file.
Dang it.
I'm just, I keep getting met with the same picture of that flip-flop every time I look through my camera.
Ew.
It is, you know?
Yeah, I'll stop looking.
Chunky.
I've never had any of those that chunky.
Just a little bit of chunk mostly.
Yeah, I've had some pretty large chunks.
I don't like the feeling of the chunks.
I feel like I can feel it like warp out, like, like, like.
You did not just make that sound.
That was the sound of this with the corpse out of your pooch.
No, it's true.
It goes like, it's so aggressive.
And it hurts and you can feel it coming between your, your lips at her.
It's like you giving birth.
That was literally.
But like the thing that sucks about pads is like, I don't know.
I know you don't wear them, but like getting your hair stuck in the glue is so painful.
It is, that's why I don't wear them.
It's coming out.
Get your hair stuck in the glue.
And also, like, when you have a big, a big glue or piece like that, it like doesn't suck it up.
It doesn't suck it up at all.
It just sits on the pad and then it's wet and then you sit in it.
And then your whole, then your whole Gucci's like covered in blood at that point.
It's really gross.
It is gross.
And sometimes it gets stuck in your hair.
And then you have to rip the clot out of your hair.
It's so painful.
Did you know, did you know that they didn't start testing pads on real period blood until recently?
I did not know that.
Why?
I don't know.
Let me just hear a blood.
Let me just make sure that I'm not lying, spreading in lies on the internet right now.
Misinformation.
Bless you.
Thank you.
From 2023, no one studied menstrual product observancy realistically up until now.
So they did a study and found that many menstrual products had a much lower or higher liquid
capacity than advertised when real blood was used instead of saline.
They used saline.
Salt water.
Yeah, I guess so.
That is not the same thing at all.
That is not the same.
Make sure of water, salt and bicarbonate.
That is not the same thing at all.
Yeah, people don't lie on the internet.
I lie on the internet.
No, you don't.
You always tell the truth.
I always tell the truth on the internet.
Exactly.
Pads were used as medical gods for bullet wounds.
Nurses just said, Hey, this is useful.
Good for the nurses.
Nurses saved us.
It's the same reason that you went.
I heard you could use like a tampon and shove it in like a really deep wound if you have to.
I've never done that before though.
I've never done that either.
But thank you for the tip.
I'll keep that in mind in case I get a bullet wound.
You're welcome.
Thank you.
Well, do you ever want to have kids or you said no, right?
I kind of can't.
Yeah, you said you can't, right?
Yeah, maybe, I don't know.
I feel like I'm too young for me to sit here and be like, yeah, cause once you have kids,
you can never turn back, you know?
Yeah, sure.
Well, you can put them up for adoption, but then like,
That's true.
Then you feel bad.
Yeah, then you feel bad.
It's like adopting a pet and then returning it like you feel bad.
That's bad.
You shouldn't do that.
Yeah.
Yeah, cause I, this, all this period talk reminded me of like the girl with the list on TikTok who like
made a whole list of everything that can go wrong if you get pregnant and it's like your teeth will fall out.
Your, your feet will swell, your fucking kids will smear poop on your walls or they'll just poop inside of you.
That's true.
Yeah, they'll poop inside of you or like, I don't know, try to think of all the other ones.
Like you can get allergic to water or something or you can get allergic to your own sweat.
Oh yeah, you can, you get new allergies.
Yeah.
And then your fucking armpits will start to lactate or something.
That is a new sentence.
I heard of that where like, like the, the milk starts to get stored in your armpits too.
Yeah.
Oh wait, I want to, wait, I want to clarify something.
I have endometriosis and it's, it's hard to have kids when you have endo.
Yeah.
So even if I had like a surrogate, I mean, I don't know the science of this, but I don't know if it would even survive.
A surrogate, do you mean like you'd put your own egg in someone else and another lady's body?
Oh, I thought, I thought you mean like somebody like puts their sperm in my, in my coochie.
I thought you meant, sorry, I was thinking the wrong way.
That's not a surrogate.
But I thought, but like a sperm donor.
Yeah, that's a sperm donor.
A surrogate is for the mom.
Oh, they're different.
Yeah, surrogacy is for the mother.
Yeah.
So if I, I take my, wait, how does that work?
So I take my egg and put someone's nut in her womb?
Yeah, you can put both.
You can put your egg in someone else's nut in her womb.
Yeah.
Oh, I don't know how I feel about that.
And yeah, it's kind of fucked up because you're just using her for her.
Yeah.
And then it costs a lot of money.
And like you, I kind of, if I, if I were going to be a mom, I'd kind of want my own, like my own experience, no offense.
I would not want my own experience at all.
Absolutely not.
I'm terrified running the oven.
Yeah. Cause it's like part of pregnancy is the trauma.
Oh, you want to live through it?
Yeah.
But like, aren't you scared?
Like, you know, your, your, your fault, your fucking cervix can fall out.
Like your womb can fall out afterwards.
Yeah.
Your butthole can fall out.
Your butthole can fall out too.
That too.
I don't know.
Like you want, you want, you're okay with that?
I want to be a victim.
You're already a victim.
But like, you know, like how you look at a big old pregnant bitch and she can barely work.
And you're like, wow, I feel bad for her.
I want people to feel that way about me.
Damn, she's a big old pregnant bitch.
She can't work.
I want people to like wait on my, my every need, you know?
Oh, you.
So you just want people to like help you with stuff.
Yeah.
I'm a fat ass pregnant bitch.
Do you work for me?
That's probably shallow.
Just how you're made.
You know, a lot of pregnant women don't even get work done for them either too.
But I don't want to pay anybody.
I want it to be free.
I want people to pity me.
I don't think people will pity you just because you're pregnant.
Really?
You don't, you don't look at a big old pregnant woman in Walmart and she's like trying to bend over
because she dropped her phone.
You don't feel bad for her.
I feel kind of bad.
Okay.
But do you go and help her?
No.
I just sit there and stare and watch her fight for her life.
That's what I'm saying.
Okay.
You have a point.
That's like what I see is somebody who falls and they're just laying on the floor.
I just stare.
That's what I'm saying.
You don't go and help her.
Okay.
You have a point.
I have been corrected.
You just want to be pampered, right?
That's the thing.
Yeah.
Don't get pregnant just to get pampered.
It's not going to happen.
But then I get like people give me extra food because they see I'm like fat and hungry because
I'm eating for two.
Well, I don't know.
You can, you can, there's other ways to get pampered.
It doesn't have to be through pregnancy.
I don't know.
Become paralyzed.
Become a vegetable and then you'll have people do everything for you.
That's a good point.
Yeah.
I'm going to sever my spinal cord.
Okay.
Good luck.
Don't die.
I probably will, but it's okay.
Oh, a sugar daddy.
Do you want a sugar daddy?
Is that what you want?
I'll take a sugar anything.
A sugar anything.
A sugar grandma.
As she has the money, I'll do anything.
That hold on.
Hold on.
Why are they talking about nugget?
Become a nugget.
Oh, that's why.
Okay.
Is that like a slur for a vegetable?
You don't know when it's like nugget prawn.
Like, you don't know nugget?
Like the tag?
No.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, something.
It's coming back to me.
Wait, is that like amputee shit?
Yeah, but like amputee everything.
Like no limbs at all.
I like that.
I'm just kidding.
Sometimes I look at that and I'm like, oh,
well, at least I could get somebody to feed me.
I kind of understand.
See, that's also the, the, um,
that's the appeal for me too,
because people make fun of me for being into nugget.
I'm not actually into it, but we joke about it.
And I get, that's the appeal for me too.
Like, yeah, someone will feed me and like take care of me
and do everything for me.
Yeah, I'll be your little nugget pet.
I can't run away.
That's what I'm saying.
That's appealing.
It is.
It really is.
It's like the thought of it.
Yeah.
The thought of it is, the thought of it is appealing.
Then she judges us for knowing Derpixon.
I didn't judge you for knowing Derpixon.
I'm just saying this is like Derpixon was very,
uh, what's it called, but, uh,
basic.
It was like, you know,
Yeah, it's very vanilla.
Yeah.
Very average, uh,
just take the pillow princess title instead.
But like pillow princess, except in every, um,
in every situation in life ever, do everything.
That's how I want to be.
Yeah.
Me too.
Just do everything for me.
Passenger princess, pillow princess, life princess.
Just do everything.
That's just rot maxing.
Your mom is rot maxing.
I already do rot max except I don't have anyone to take care of me
while I'm rotting.
Me too.
Same, same, same.
You said he's someone to, to help me rot.
Move me from the bed to the couch
so I can rot while watching TV or something.
And your skin can melt into the couch.
Oh my God, do you know that case?
Wait, did we talk about that?
You told me about it.
Yeah, we did.
We talked about that.
I remember now.
I saw the pictures.
Yeah, I remember now.
Yeah, you can melt into the couch.
Jerky.
Except they didn't take care of her,
so that's why she rotted into the couch.
No.
Yeah.
That's a skill issue.
For the parents, like, yes.
No, I mean, I mean, like the skin being melted into the couch.
Oh, that wouldn't happen to you?
That wouldn't happen to me.
I'm so, I'm so hydrated.
My skin would not fall off and melt into a couch.
But the point was that she couldn't hydrate herself.
Oh.
I thought she was just tired.
No.
That was not what happened.
Oh.
Okay, I think I'm missing some context.
Yeah, you're missing some context.
I'm going to chew your food and baby bird you.
See, that's disgusting.
But like, I don't know.
What are your thoughts?
Um, baby, baby mama for the food.
That's disgusting.
You're going to get a disease.
No, but it is a little.
See, the problem is if someone like,
words it well enough for me,
I end up like thinking, you know what,
maybe it's not that bad.
Like spitting in the mouth?
Yeah, like it's just one step above that.
Okay, that's true.
Yeah.
Are you into getting your mouth sped in?
Sure, why not?
Yeah, exactly.
You don't have to chew.
You could just swallow.
Yeah, just disgusting.
What if they want to snowball you?
I need to, I feel like I don't quite understand
the meaning of snowball.
Exactly.
That's when you, when you kiss with gum, right?
But like, how?
You suck it into your mouth and you kiss.
The act with gum is passed from one person.
Okay, yeah, that sounds nice.
That sounds fun.
How romantic.
It is romantic.
Don't you think it's romantic?
I guess so, yeah.
Because you wouldn't do that with just anybody.
Yeah.
I thought you were freaky.
You're so, you're so chill.
I guess, I guess.
I'm holding myself back.
Don't.
Oh, wait, no, I guess if you have to hold yourself back.
Yeah.
If this is my PL, I'd be a little bit more honest, but...
Well, it's not.
We should...
Here, I'll give you, ask me any question.
I'll answer it completely honestly.
Be wise.
I don't know.
I don't want to get you canceled.
I'm already getting canceled.
Guys, chat, what do you want to ask her?
I don't know.
I don't want to get you canceled.
Yeah, pin the blame on chat.
That way you can't get in trouble.
Yeah, exactly.
Piss-naxing.
Do it, stink!
Really?
Out of all the questions you could ask, you asked me if it stinks.
Yes, it does.
Is it pink?
It is pink.
I'm a white woman.
Yes.
Body count, 500.
I don't think I can answer that.
I might actually get in trouble.
Okay, here.
What's your fantasy there?
You can answer that.
I have to speak in, like, YouTube terms.
Speak in YouTube terms.
Go ahead.
How do I...
I'm going to type it too, because I don't know how to say this out loud.
Do you want me to translate it into YouTube?
Yeah, no.
No, I think I can...
Wait, hold on.
I'll just say it.
Grape.
I like grapes.
Grapes are delicious.
A big ol' grape.
You're very welcome here.
We love grape, too.
We love grapes.
I like purple grapes.
You'll fit right in.
We love grapes.
I'm actually doing a grape audio with Sheebie.
Is that legal?
I don't know.
It's not on Patreon, so yeah.
Oh, okay.
I just asked her, I was like,
Yo, Sheebie, are you into grapes?
And she said, yeah, let's do it.
Grapes are delicious.
And then we...
We actually recorded it together while in VC.
Oh, immersion.
A real immersion.
Got any grapes?
Bum, bum, bum.
I know that one.
At least you know something.
Not TF2, not Gmod, not Newgrounds,
but I'll take the grapes.
I'll take the grapes.
Grape dojin is like 99% of my searches.
I don't look at dojin that much.
Got any grapes?
Bum, bum, bum.
Who eats the grape in the audio?
Me?
The obvious answer.
Oh, really?
Wait, wait, what does eating the grape mean?
Who is the one receiving the grape?
Me, obviously.
Yeah, of course.
Yeah.
Of course.
It's just on Twitter, but I haven't posted it yet.
I've been lazy about editing it.
Editing takes forever.
I don't like it.
Do you edit your own audio?
Oh, yeah.
You do?
What do you do to them?
Nothing.
I just chop them up, and then sometimes I'll add a filter,
and then that's it.
What do you mean a filter?
Like, sometimes I'll adjust the sliders on the equalizer kind of thing.
Oh, okay, because I don't know anything about audio.
I just copy the same YouTube tutorial I found a long time ago,
and that's all I do.
But I don't know much about audio editing either.
I kind of don't either.
My mic settings were also copied from another guy's.
Yeah, it took me like three years to figure out my mic settings.
I couldn't scream for the longest time without my mic cutting out,
and it was so frustrating.
All of my previous clips, the funniest clips I have from the past,
is all me screaming and then getting muted because of my mic settings.
I hate that.
I hate when that happens.
It ruins the entire clip.
It ruins the whole clip.
I could never post any clips of the funny moments
because it's like you can't even hear what I'm saying.
Yeah, because it's just like, ah!
I hate that.
Yeah, it's because of the background sound filter, that one.
Oh yeah, I think it's an OBS filter too.
Yeah, it's just called background noise.
The noise suppression.
Yeah, something like that.
Turn it off and your screens will no longer be cut off.
You're welcome.
It took me three years to figure that one out.
You don't like grapes, but there's purple grapes and green grapes.
There's all variety of grapes.
There's grapes for everybody.
I mean, not everyone has to like grapes.
That's true.
Yeah, we don't know.
But there's a wide variety of grapes to choose from.
There is.
I personally like loving grapes.
The grape that smells bad.
That's very sweet.
Yeah.
The grape that smells bad.
I like that.
What would concord grape classify?
What's concord?
That's a kind of, I think that's a very generic grape, I think.
I've never heard of concord.
What is, what?
It's like a purple grape, right?
Is that multiple grape?
I mean, multiple grapes at once with multiple grapes.
That's crazy.
Grapes with a giant sausage is a great meal.
That is not a balanced meal.
I'm so confused.
Seedless grape?
I do prefer my grape seedless.
Yeah.
No, I like my grape with seed.
You like seed?
I can handle a little bit of seed, but I just don't, it gets a little too, I don't like a lot in my mouth.
That's fair.
Yeah.
Ooh, I want to try the cotton candy grapes.
They look so good.
Is that real?
Yeah, they're like really sweet grapes.
Oh, I thought they were actually flavored like cotton candy.
But a seed might grow a plant.
We'll just have to kill the plant.
Kill the plant?
Oh, kill it.
Is this like a brand?
I think it's like, they're like big sweet grapes, I think.
I love me a big, big sweet grape.
Me too, me too.
We're flip-flopping between different types of grape here.
That's okay.
There's grape for all of us.
Have you ever tried growing any plants before?
Yeah, but they always die.
Same.
I just, I don't, yeah, don't trust me with a plant.
I'm trying to get into gardening because I think it's really aesthetic.
Like the look of it is pretty.
It is.
But like all of the plants I have outside on my porch are all dead.
I'm trying so hard.
That's really sad, but also relatable.
It's not aesthetic anymore.
It's just depressing looking because they're all dead.
They're just dead.
They're all dead.
I have a tomato plant and it's dying, but it's also like really trying hard to grow tomatoes too at the same time.
So it's like flopping over onto the floor while still growing tomatoes.
It's limp.
It's limp now.
That's sad.
Poor thing.
It is sad.
It's trying its hardest.
I haven't tried the tomato, maybe I should.
Fresh tomatoes are so good.
I love tomatoes.
I love tomatoes too.
I like them a lot.
I don't understand how people can dislike tomatoes.
They don't have the greatest texture, but they have a good taste.
Yeah, the texture is kind of hard to get past sometimes.
It can be, but that's why I take off the gooey part, the gooey, seedy part, and then I just eat the fleshy part of the tomato.
I don't like the gooey part.
I don't like gooey things in my mouth like that if they're food.
I cut out the seedy part of the tomato.
Yeah, it's so squishy and gross.
Yeah, I really don't like it.
Yeah, I'm huge on texture for sure.
I don't like textures of foods.
Yeah, it makes me sick when I have the wrong kind of texture.
It's enough to make me vomit actually.
Me too, me too, me too.
What food is the worst texture for you?
I'm going to get shit on so hard for this, but I don't like grilled onions.
No, I don't like them either.
It's like they're half squishy and half like crunchy and it's like slimy.
I don't like it.
Yeah, it's like slimy.
I know what you mean.
I try really hard because I like the taste of onion rings, but I don't like the texture of the onion inside the onion rings.
Yeah, me too.
So it's really frustrating.
I know what you mean.
Grilled onions are kind of gross.
I personally, I don't like it when I eat stuff that's supposed to be mushy, but it has chunks on it, like yogurt with chunks on it.
That's gross.
Or like, I don't like mushrooms either, but I just don't like the taste of mushrooms in general.
I always got shit on for not liking mushrooms.
Me too.
I was always told they're a flavor sponge.
If you don't like how they taste, it's because the flavor you're putting into is bad.
We'll shut the fuck up.
I just don't like mushrooms.
They taste like dirt.
They do taste like dirt.
A lot of vegetables taste like dirt, to be honest.
They do.
A lot of vegetables taste like dirt.
And yes, I wash them.
I wash them.
They still taste like dirt.
They taste like shit, dude.
They really do.
They really taste like nothing.
It's the texture and the taste.
Good dirt.
There's no such thing as good dirt, but like good dirt.
But you know, yeah, grilled onions remove the bite.
If you made me choose between a raw onion and grilled onions, I would eat grilled onions.
Me too.
Me too, yeah.
Raw onion.
I don't know why people would want to eat a raw onion.
That's crazy.
I don't know.
Maybe they're shrek.
The acid breath.
Gonna change your pH balance.
Holy crap.
Do people eat raw onions?
I've seen this girl on TikTok who eats raw onions.
Ew.
Yeah, it is ew.
And it's like a purple onion.
Oh, brussels sprouts are gross too.
Ew, I don't like them.
I like broccoli.
You like broccoli?
I like it better when it's raw because it's crunchy.
I don't like broccoli.
Broccoli tastes like ass.
And smells like ass.
It smells like a fart.
Exactly.
Thank you.
Every single time I say that broccoli smells bad, people are like, what do you mean broccoli
doesn't smell like anything?
It smells like a fart.
It really does.
It smells like dookie.
And no one has believed me until now.
Thank you, Momosa.
People are always like a broccoli.
Does it smell like anything?
It smells like a fart.
It does.
Especially when you grill them or not grill them when you steam them or whatever and
you put butter.
It smells like butter and hot ass.
Butter and hot ass.
Yes.
You like carrots?
I'm okay with carrots.
I can handle carrots.
I love carrots.
They're just like carrots.
I just don't like how carrots are like bitter.
I don't know.
I don't like bitter stuff.
That's true.
I feel like some carrots taste kind of bitter.
When I was younger, my dad used to try to convince me to eat carrots because he would
open the carrot.
Well, actually, I think he genuinely thought this.
I don't know.
He's the kind of guy that's like, oh, if you eat enough vegetables, you could cure your
cancer.
But I had really bad eyesight since I was a kid.
So he cut open a carrot and he was like, look inside the carrot.
What's the fun?
And I looked inside the carrot and I was like, I don't see anything in the carrot.
Bro is schizo-maxing.
What?
And he said, look inside the carrot.
There's an eye in the carrot.
What?
I think he was a strange man.
But I was like, dad, I don't see anything inside the carrot.
And he was like, there's an eye inside the carrot.
And if you eat enough carrots, it'll cure your eyesight because like I had bad eyesight
since I was a child.
Yeah.
And that's how he would try to convince me to eat more carrots because there were eyes
inside of the carrot.
That's so creepy.
Yeah.
What's your prescription for your glasses?
It's around negative five.
Do you know like if you're like, are you 2100?
I don't know.
Is that a thing you use in Canada?
No, maybe, but I don't, I don't have it like memorized.
Oh, okay.
I don't remember my like, I have myopia.
That's like far up near, near sided, I think.
So does that mean like close things are blurry?
So when I can't see from far away, I might have 2100 vision in both eyes, which is like,
I think I'm halfway there to being legally blind.
Diopters.
Okay, 2100 is between negative two and negative three, it says.
Oh, so yours is worse than mine.
Yeah, I'm at 2400.
You're legally blind.
No, I'm not.
That's crazy.
Yes, you are.
What is legally blinding?
I think here in America isn't it 2200 is legally blind?
What is legally blind?
Yeah, 2200 is considered legally blind in America.
What does legally blind even mean?
You can't drive.
Oh, that's it.
Yeah, of course I can't drive with the light glasses.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm very lucky, but I'm just built different.
Is yours corrected to 2020?
I think so, yeah.
Yeah, mine's corrected to 2020.
Yeah.
Yeah, without the glasses.
Yeah, I have it on my driver's license.
Me too, yeah.
Yeah, don't drive without your glasses, but I think I could do it.
I think I could pull it off.
I've done it before.
Well, yours is okay.
I think you can do it for sure.
I just have to be careful.
I wouldn't be able to see like a squirrel or anything running across the road.
Poor squirrel.
Maybe if like it was a small child.
It's going to get turned into roadkill.
Yeah, both of them.
Okay.
I think I'll stop the collab here because I've been holding in my pee for the last hour.
For me, just for me.
Just for you.
Ah.
Oh my God, the most is an emanated joyer.
I am.
Momosa, did you want to keep streaming?
No, I'm actually starving.
Okay.
Do you want to read the same person?
Yeah, who should I read?
Um, who should she be streaming?
Let me just make sure she's not ending.
Okay.
Gotta ship it.
She be three hours.
I'm a need.
Oh my God, she has a cat cam.
That's so cute.
Hi.
Um.
She be say something.
She be, are you gonna keep streaming?
Okay.
She's playing faith.
I don't know what faith is.
It's not a bad game.
It's very religious though.
Did you see she got her tan model?
Is that the tan model?
Wait, really?
Yeah, she be got a tan model.
I'm clicking right now.
Yeah.
Oh, she, oh, that's so cute.
I like it.
Did she answer my question?
I accidentally clicked off.
I don't know.
Okay.
Well, let's just read her and hope she doesn't need to end.
Uh.
Bye.
So and holy trinity.
Thank you guys for joining our collab.
It was the collab of all time.
It definitely was.
We had a lot of interesting conversations.
For sure.
She just said hi.
You learned a lot.
That's good.
I hope you learned a lot about us and our blood clots and our periods.
I hope you did.
She said yes, apparently.
So I guess we could write her.
Okay.
Good.
Thank you guys.
Have a fun time in, uh, in she be stream.
Um, um, see you.
Yeah.
Thank you for watching.
It's so awkward ending a collab.
Bye.
Yeah.